en Irán meses de protestas contra el
gobierno han visto también contra
manifestaciones como la protesta de este
domingo donde miles de personas se
reunieron Para apoyar a la República
islámica el mismo día el fiscal general
de la república comunicó que la policía
de la moral había sido clausurada por el
gobierno una medida que estos peregrinos
iraníes en Irak recibieron con
ambivalencia
corresponde a los expertos en la materia
juzgar Si la policía de la moral debe
permanecer o no pero está estipulado por
ley y como cualquier otra ley la gente
debe respetarlo el país se ha visto
sacudido por protestas inéditas tras la
muerte de masa a mini en septiembre la
mujer falleció tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral que la acusó de
llevar de forma inadecuada la suspensión
de esta unidad policial cuyo único
objetivo es controlar la vestimenta de
las mujeres es una aparente concesión a
las demandas de los manifestantes por
mayores libertades sin embargo muchos
usuarios de las redes sociales yranías
se mostraron escépticos de que aunque
ésta Se disuelva hay algún cambio
significativo es una desinformación que
la República es la mica de Irán haya
abolido su publicidad de la moral es una
táctica para detener el levantamiento
los manifestantes no se enfrentan a las
armas y a las balas para abolir la
policía de la moral o el Jack forzado
quieren acabar con el régimen islámico
tras los comentarios del fiscal los
manifestantes en Irán convocaron una
huelga de tres días para seguir
presionando a régimen la organización
Irán Newman write estima que al menos
448 personas perdieron la vida a manos
de las fuerzas de seguridad desde el
inicio de las protestas